hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we will learn
about the most common Excel errors and
how to fix them that said if these are
the type of videos you'd like to watch
then hit that like And subscribe buttons
and the bell icon to get notified just
for a quick info if you want to upscale
yourself master business analytics
skills land your dream job or grow in
your career then you must explore simply
loar scit of various business analytics
programs simply Lear offers postgraduate
programs from P University in
collaboration with Amazon Google and
Microsoft through this program you will
gain the knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like prescriptive
and Predictive Analytics regression
classification and over a dozen others
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts in Top
Tire product companies and academic from
top universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a business analytics
role as a fresher or moved on to a
higher paying job profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and a
description box below to find out the
business analytics program that fits
your experience and areas of interests
now without further delay let's get
started so some of the common Excel
errors and how to fix them so let's get
back to the Excel spreadsheet with some
data on it so there you go we have
switch to Excel spreadsheet and here you
can already see there is one common
error so this hashing right you can see
some hash symbols over here so basically
they are not any practical errors this
is just the visual error which you can
commonly see whenever you have opened a
new data set so in those situations all
you can do is is adjust the column width
and row height right in those scenarios
if you do that you can fix these errors
simple now let's get to the second type
of error now uh let's say we have salary
and Hike percentage over here right now
let's try to calculate the new salary so
the formula is equals to Old salary plus
height percentage which is in the cell
E2 into the old existing salary close
the bracket press enter so there you go
you have the updated salaries here now
let's say I remove this now you have the
actual salary so far it looks okay right
even if I remove this particular cell
it's showing the actual value but what
if your data set wanted or the architect
or the owner of the spreadsheet wanted
to have a clean looking data and he
added some information here what's the
reason for this missing value let's say
he will say no hike given to this
particular particular employee based on
performance right and if I get out of
this cell you can see we already have a
value error right so we don't want this
error basically what's happening is here
we have a different data type Al
together we were dealing with numbers so
far but when the formula finds a text
formula or text data type then it will
show a value error so basically this is
based on uh data type right so here you
can see when you highlight the cell a
value is used in the formula of the
wrong data type so most common errors
can be fixed with this method help on
this error and you can find all the help
that you can get from Excel and it will
also suggest you what to do in these
particular situations now a common
solution which you can do to eliminate
this error
is encapsulate this
particular hike cell with a function
sum right and enter now this will bypass
that particular value error and it will
eliminate it now if we drag the same
formula across all the cells okay let's
try to remove a few and uh yeah this one
as well let's say they did not perform
in this particular quarter so no hike no
hike and as soon as we get out of this
cell and drag this formula across all
the cells I think it's already been
approved and then you will not find the
value error and moving on to the next
type of error so uh before that let's
try to enter some value here let's
say
I'm doing this deliberately so to
understand this error we need this so
now we have a new versions of Microsoft
Excel right so the error that we are
going to discuss is the spill error okay
now here we have employee IDs so employe
ID will anyways be unique but still we
will try to eliminate some D duplicate
entries by using the unique formula here
and if I give this particular a to a
column and and press enter you will find
the error that says spill the answer is
I mean what does exactly this mean is
you can see the particular cells got
highlighted so these particular cells
got highlighted because it wants to fill
these spaces with the unique entries but
unfortunately it could not because it
has already some data in its path so in
this path it has simply learn so where
an existing
value is present in a uh you know set of
cells where it wants to print it will
not print the data and let's see what
happens if I remove this you got the
data right so that's how it works now
this is the second type of error which
was spill error now let's move on to the
third type of error in Excel now let's
remove this column now let's go all the
way to the bottom and let's say uh your
manager wanted to find out um what's the
increase in the um you know dedicated
amount for salaries old salary and new
salary so now let's try to calculate the
sum of all these columns so let's say I
don't know the function and I presume
there is some function which is called
as ADD and all the cells I think it will
give me the required uh submission
detail right like keep this and I think
it should work but it's not this happens
it is identifying that you want to do
sumission but it is unable to you know
get a Clarity uh and automatically when
it doesn't have a Clarity it will throw
up an error instead of taking a decision
on its own okay so it will tell you I
think it you want to uh do a submission
but you're using the wrong function so
when you click on this error
same uh when you click on this error it
will show you highlighted error symbol
will be popping up somewhere so when you
click on that error it will tell that
the name error will come when you're
trying to name the function in a wrong
way let's say I delete this and again
let's say I give s u in place of sum and
I give the entire column salary enter it
again shows me the name error right so
basically it's unable to identify by the
function or you are giving a wrong name
to the function so in such situations
all you can do is use the right name
press T to select the function and
select the entire column press enter
there you go and here sync let's say
equals to
sum press tab to enter the function
select the column enter and you can find
out the difference between the both you
can simply
this one minus this
one okay the data type again equals this
minus this enter so this is the amount
that invested that got invested extra
for clearing the
hikes now that was the other type of
error now let's move on to the next type
so before that let's try to delete this
one we don't want any complications now
the next type of error is reference
error hash ref now if I happen to delete
this particular column let's say I
delete this and you can already see a
lot of ref ref ref has been popped up so
what is this so this happens basically
when you let's say you have created a
formula using the multiple cells and one
of the cells get deleted so now every
formula that you created using in
multiple cells the Excel was referring
to that particular cell for getting the
you know final result but out of that if
any of the sales get deleted then it is
unable to refer to that particular
address and it's not g able to give you
the result now if I delete this
particular column the same happens so
what's happening here is if you check
the formula equals to you can see some
cells got highlighted the C column and E
column so it is refering to these two
cells and it is performing some
mathematical operations in the
background and giving you the final
result but when you're removing these
reference cells it will automatically
throw an error which is Hash rep now
moving next so for the next type of
error uh let's do
something so what we're doing is we
have
so we have salary per month now we have
this particular salary right the updated
salary per month now let's see we wanted
to calculate the uh pay per day now that
can be done divided by
30 enter so this is the average amount
which an employee gets per day on per
day basis now let's say I give it is
zero right if you divide that by zero or
let's say now I've deliberately given
the number a zero but in few situations
when the result you know sometimes the
calculations are dependent on
intermediate results right intermediate
calculations so in case if any of the
cell is yielding in a value zero during
the intermediate calculations then in
those scenarios you find the divide by
zero error so this happens in that
situation and also when you highlight
this it is also seeing when the cell is
empty in a few situations during the
data cleaning process if you end up
having a blank cell in those scenarios
as well you can find this divide by Z
error now let's move on to the next type
of error in our tutorial for today let's
clear this column as well I don't want
to complications during the
demonstration now uh let's look at some
of the advanced uh functions let's say I
want to run a v lookup function over
here let's say I
want name and high here so I'll add them
here to we look up now the lookup value
will be my employee
ID it's taking an entire column let's
say I'll not do that I'll add
another um cell okay I'll refer to this
particular cell and I'll add the emplo
is there and the table array is this you
can just highlight somewhere over here
because this is a table it will take up
the entire
table okay it took
it okay let let me personally do it
manually do because it's taking also
taking the V look up one so I'll like
the entire
array now the next one
is
go we look up I'll refer to this
particular
cell this is my
array uh the high percentage so 1 2 3 4
5 comma exact
match and press on Tab to select it and
enter okay now let
me put back the ID column here and you
can see we are getting na because uh we
haven't added any of the details over
here so you can either uh do a data
validation here or you can just add up
the value here
enter now I have you know uh stretched
the formula across all the values here
right so you know I'm just I just want
one value here I'm just getting uh let's
say your manager wants some random value
over here wants to get the detail of the
detail only of one person let's say this
particular person did not get hike right
so this is fine it is showing me uh the
you know hike
value it is showing me the hike uh
percentage or you know some
value of that person but again why am I
getting all these errors I don't want
this errors here how can I remove them
so in such scenarios you can uh directly
tell
formula in case if you find an error
then you can say or you can you don't
have to add add anything just keep it as
blank all right in such scenarios you
don't uh have any errors there now you
can copy and paste the employee ID over
here and done or you can do a quick data
validation here right just go to data
and data
validation
and instead of any value select the list
and Source will be the list of your
employee IDs and press okay now let's
say your manager wants to check
individually now this particular person
how much hike did he get and uh one n
this particular person did he get any
hike or no no right so this is how you
can uh use uh if error to remove the N
errors not uh applicable or not want
something such type of errors and these
are the most most common type of errors
that you will be finding in day-to-day
life using your Excel and with that we
have come to an end of this session on
the most common Excel errors and how to
fix them if you have any doubts
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if require any of the
resources like dat set and formula list
which has more fixes to most errors
found we have a separate document on
that if you want any of those please do
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts we'll be more
than happy to help you at the earliest
until next time thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from Simply Lear
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber secur
AI machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here